[Music]
we're in Nashville Airport as you can
see it's beautiful very picturesque got
a bit of indigestion in fact I've now
had indigestion permanently through this
trip because that's how rich the food
has been we're going to Los Angeles the
City of Angels
we're looking forward to it
[Music]
we're on our flight to L.A we got some
food before because they don't give a
few food here and we've been sitting
here not able to eat it for at least 20
minutes I'm very
angry this is my food mate
it's not natural Gary I mean it looks
depressing that's what it looks like
mate I'm just very angry very frustrated
very sad I gave him a little playful
punch in the pancetta today just playful
yeah it turns out it's rock hard right
solid full of food it's cholesterol mate
that in a poor digestive system yeah
we're seeing a bridge at Fantasy
tomorrow yeah lunch we're cheek she's
asked us to order a bunch of food from a
takeaway yeah he made me order healthy
food yeah I sent her a list and she went
walk like what are you all sick or
something yes on the list of food and to
be fair at this point we kind of are
yeah our digestive systems are kind of
struggling after everything that we've
had I mean New York and Nashville in
particular was just brutal mate
basically my colon is now like the M25
at Rochelle
I'm not well I'm like Elvis on his last
days
in Rock Way well you know I always die
didn't you yeah no he had a heart attack
on the John I'm about yeah I'm about
three weeks away from that mate are you
also a big fan of the teenagers
no I taught them horrible things good
dog thank you thank you all right boys
and girls we're off to L.A unless you
when we're there
that's a very good movie if you've never
seen it that's one of the movies
Basketball Diaries yeah really good
movie true story you love your
documentary it's not it's not a
documentary it's like a biopics don't
you yeah I do
but there's a lot of people who are not
paying for logs if you do pay it I can
buy a new bag I can get a little
colostomy bag and I'll be able to
compete in and out so you need to up
your game don't you you a pain for me to
commit I'm a tolerant man yeah and I've
stood by you yeah through the sex
scandals yeah the court case never
proven the script I had a great legal
team and we got off if you get a
colostomy bag you're off the show
that's oppression
[Music]
see what you've made the baby do I know
you're problematic exactly
it's your pleasure welcome you to Los
Angeles
[Music]
so here we are L.A
first thing I'd say everybody's wearing
a mask or a lot more people are wearing
a mask number one number two they don't
seem to realize me wearing this hat is
ironic giving me the stink eye what
we're doing is just foreign
corridors yeah this is what I like this
man it's just an endless Corridor
the quality of life for people here at
the same amount of money is just insane
I mean look at those houses yeah
[Applause]
and that's just like a normal family
home here yeah
[Music]
so here we are in one of the roughest
parts of LA West Side the gangs are all
around us as you can see the homeless
encampments the drugs I mean they're
probably selling Coke in there do you
know what I mean yeah absolutely look at
that Gaffney that is
that is sensational
we're walking to have a bit of breakfast
lovely and then we're going for lunch
with Bridger fantasy we're going for
lunch with bridgie yeah she's had a baby
recently but she was so moved and
inspired by a Rogan podcast she wants to
have a chat with us so we're gonna piss
off some more comedians I don't think
it's pretty possible we had a trans
woman comedian use that term very
Loosely challenge us to a boxing fight
which I really didn't think was very
ladylike Behavior she said she had more
testosterone than both of us which I
mean it's probably true but it kind of
contradicts some of what anyway oh what
a world the incredible thing is here
it's like a really nice place to walk
but no one walks everyone drives yeah it
does explain why you're all so fat
so anyway we're gonna go get something
to eat and probably get charged 400 for
the privilege sayonara
It's So Posh you need to sign in I don't
really understand that no I mean it's a
bit much in it we're gonna get a table
but you had to sign in give your blood
sample tell me what your star sign was
so we're not going to do that but we are
going to do we're gonna get some food to
take away like real men
because birds don't do takeaways just
men
mate by the way we should talk about
this people are [ __ ] crazy here with
the master [ __ ] like yeah they still
think like we're in the middle of a
massive Global pandemic I mean technical
what do you mean it is still a pandemic
covert is a hoax man
foreign
[Music]
the incredible moments and delights that
we've had with friends on this trip but
also swearing a thought for those who
are shruggling those who are finding
life difficult maybe spare a thought for
them and also be truly grateful for what
we have amen amen what do you think I
think it's nice mate yeah mate
another ship plagiarizing me right and
we're going Rogan I'm my usual
diplomatic self yeah we're almost
diplomatic what do you mean you were
diplomatic he went British comedians of
[ __ ] and you want you I agree with that
and I'm getting all the [ __ ] blame no
I'm getting the bone as well
you know what before I would have been
absolutely devastated with the way what
happened on Twitter I just couldn't give
a [ __ ] anymore you know the cool thing
when we went together as breakfast we
bumped into a guy he was oh guys I love
it do you know what he looked like what
he was like the most handsome man you've
ever seen that and also like Hitler
would have been very proud if he'd like
managed to carve one of them out of like
whatever but you know what when I saw
him I did
I did the kind of two stages back in the
evolutionary process yeah but he was
like hey guys I love your podcast I I
work with basically yeah and we asked
him what so then he basically said
you know he tries to not piss anyone off
[ __ ] okay and he was basically saying we
have to deal with all the crap that
you're talking about do you want another
tomato
Anton come and eat something
[Music]
morning everybody so this is the big day
we're interviewing Sam Harris and Adam
Carolla today we booked a special Studio
a place that we could record that
interview we're not sure it's going to
be big enough let's show you inside yeah
let's go inside my let's crack on
just remember we booked this without
seeing it first all right okay
I did not expect it to look like this so
we're going to set up the set here by
moving all the equipment that all the
chairs it's not going to look like this
we're going to use this space here
just to let you know that thanks to
locals we put a down payment on this
house
this is now where I live do you have any
idea how much this place costs it is I
mean look look at this [ __ ] and that's
why you need to subscribe of your
subscriptions this is where I should
live this is kind of embarrassing this
is ridiculous we did not expect I
actually feel guilty being here I don't
I [ __ ] love it this is where I
deserve to be anyway we gotta go and set
up because Sam Harris is coming in a
couple of hours then we're off to Adam
Carolla studio to record that we'll keep
you updated thanks for making this
possible I guess it wasn't the plan I
feel weird no the sun is that I mean May
should we just sack off the interviews
and just get in the pool look at that
son Yeah so basically what we're saying
is that we're now La podcasters [ __ ] the
UK yeah give us money because this is
what I deserve
sayonara money's run out mate we've only
got money for yogurt you think we're
living this glamorous influencer
lifestyle mate
I'm now down to eating what the [ __ ] is
ancient grain granola why have I got
hemp in my
I don't understand that I mate who puts
hemp in their [ __ ] cereal
get into Show Business it'll be
glamorous I said I mean to be fair this
is pretty [ __ ] glamorous in it but
still just slopping you're getting to a
bowl one more day
well we're going back tomorrow and we're
going back tomorrow evening but we're
interviewing Sam Harris in a matter of
hours Adam Carolla and Billy the bird
so I'm going to introduce him and then
I'm going to ask if we can be best
friends
I think we'll be best friends we've got
a lot in common uh just follow me this
way around
[Music]
remember my podcast with Ricky Gervais
was that was yeah I was in London
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so welcome everybody we're
still in Los Angeles we had just done an
incredible two-hour interview with Sam
Harris a big chunk of it for locals
thank you
now listen great to have you on the show
thank you for first of all for letting
us tear up your set sure in order to do
this
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
like an inflexible chimpanzee
I don't know about chimpanzee but you do
look inflexible man do you know what I
mean and I just look like I'm failing an
IQ test right I packed it all right so
we just interviewed Adam Carolla
penultimate interview of the trip
absolutely brilliant man very very funny
very smart observations had a lot of fun
and now we're going back to our Airbnb
to get some food to get some food
finally because we are hungry we may
even partake in a little bit of that
thing the big Joey gave us because it's
legal here in California yeah crystal
meth
you do you whatever your family
traditions dictate
give me The Crystal Method go
go
singers we wouldn't have been able to do
this incredible trip without you without
your support without joining locals
without everything yeah back in London
we've come back we had a great trip
thank you very much for making it
possible we'll be doing more we're not
going to talk anymore bye
[Music]